A Donald Trump is absolutely furious that
Republicans are telling him, Stay the hell
away from Georgia. There is a Senate runoff in
Georgia of critical importance on December 6th.
It is Raphael Warnock, the incumbent Democrat
against Republican challenger Herschel Walker.
The winner on December six will determine,
do Democrats hold the Senate 5050 needing
needing every Democratic vote? And then Kamala
Harris as a tiebreaker to get things done. Or
do Democrats take a 5149 helm of the Senate making
either Joe Manchin or Kirsten Cinema a little bit
irrelevant in getting things passed? It's very
important. There is, of course, this guy named
Donald Trump who's running for president
in 2024. He wants to be seen as the savior
and the winner everywhere, despite his pretty
bad endorsement outcomes in the November 8th,
2022 midterms. And Republicans seem to recognize
if Trump comes to Georgia to, quote, help Walker,
it might actually be a really bad thing. And
there's a very interesting Rolling Stone article.
Trump is pissed. Republicans keep telling
him to stay away from Georgia. It's by as a
wind sub saying. And Nikki Ramirez. With a runoff
election looming, they write the newly announced
2024 candidate doesn't want his rivals getting
any attention while his party wards him away.
And they write as Republicans pour party
resources into the Georgia Senate runoff.
Donald Trump is getting irritated at the idea
that virtually no one of importance want him
to campaign in Georgia in the lead up. Several
Republicans and Trump allies already told him
not to hold a Georgia rally ahead of the runoff,
according to two people familiar with the matter.
Trump has, however, suggested that those close
to those close to him that he'll react poorly
if Florida's Governor Ron DeSantis, campaigns in
Georgia while the Republican Party holds its once
undisputed leader at arm's length. People who
have recently spoken to Trump fear if DeSantis
announces a Georgia event, it would guarantee
that Trump also heads to the state. Trump has
also vehemently argued to aides in confidence
that his presence in the runoff would be a net
positive for Walker. And he's accused pundits and
Republicans who say he shouldn't go to Georgia.
Are unintelligent Trump haters. I want Trump in
Georgia. I really do. Hold rallies. Talk about how
the next election is going to be rigged and how
the previous one was rigged. And it was stolen and
it was all stolen. Stand right next to Herschel
Walker and say this is one of the people we need
to get in there. But it was rigged. And how about
where's my African American and all the crazy
stuff? Do it. I think it will be bad for Herschel
Walker. If Walker wins, there is obviously
something very wrong with the people of Georgia
and the fact that Warnock didn't win outright and
we need a runoff. I've already said complete and
total disaster. I know. No question whatsoever.
We are where we are right now, which is that the
2.1% of the vote that went to the third party
candidate could go either way. And it's going to
come down to turnout and it's going to come down
to a ground game. I can think of few things worse
for Walker than what was bad for other candidates
a few weeks ago, which is Trump showing up ranting
for 90 minutes or 2 hours about voter fraud and
how he did really well in 2020, and then kind
of saying, Yeah, I'd vote for this guy or gal.
It wasn't good for the contested races. It wasn't
good for Mastriano. It wasn't good for us. It
wasn't good for Tudor Dixon. It wasn't good for
Carrie Lake. Jamba Juice lost, John Gibbs lost and
on and on and on. So I say, bring Trump to Georgia
and let him wreak havoc. Even better would be if
it becomes, for lack of a better term, a penis
size contest between Trump and DeSantis to the
detriment of Herschel Walker. We know that Barack
Obama will be campaigning with Raphael Warnock. If
the scheduling lines up, we will cover that live.
And if indeed this sort of slurry of Republican
rallies with Trump, DeSantis, etc., materialize
for Walker, we will cover those as well. But most
importantly, and I know I've said it before
and I'm gonna say it again, most importantly,
if you live in Georgia, if you're registered to
vote in Georgia, make sure that you vote because
this one is of critical importance. Make sure also
that you're subscribe to our YouTube channel. If
you're watching right now on YouTube and you look
at that subscribe button up there or down below,
wherever it is and it's enabled. If it
says subscribe rather than subscribe,
hit that button. There's over 3 million people
who watch our videos and don't yet subscribe.
Help us get to 2 million subscribers. We're
going to take a quick break and be right back.